at about 35 kilometers long
loch ness is the largest lake along the
great glen
a geological fault line that bisects
scotland
of course it's also known for its
infamous resident the loch ness monster
nicknamed nessie the rumored creature is
most often described with a small head
on a long sinuous neck with a thick body
seal-like flippers and a long tail
it almost looks prehistoric water
dwelling monsters have long been
established in scottish folklore
scottish legends include such water
beasts as giant flesh-eating waterfowl
the shape-shifting water horse and the
nine-eyed eel
but there are no folklore or literary
records that make
mention of any of these monsters
exclusively inhabiting loch ness
until nessie who doesn't want to believe
that there is some yet undiscovered
species
that's been hiding away for all these
years or better yet
a living dinosaur understanding the
legend of the loch ness monster
requires looking into hundreds of years
of lake reports
elaborate hoaxes the life of a saint and
king kong
i'm dr emily zarka and this is monstrum
it's worth noting that the actual loch
ness in the scottish highlands
is an ideal atmosphere for monsters
created from long gone glaciers the lake
is
deep and murky making it hard to see
anything clearly
fog and rain are common further
obscuring views of the lake
it's beautiful and mysterious
maybe that's part of the reason why
explanations of the creature vary
dramatically over time
a lot of theories try to explain the
loch ness monster
a lot possible explanations include
better take a deep breath for this swans
geological activity that shifts the
water's surface
odd boat wakes giant catfish giant
surgeon fish
some kind of giant mammal relative to
seals sharks
whales a dinosaur tunnels under the lake
that lead to the sea
the supernatural or misplaced ancient
marine animal
nessie's most reported form is an
aquatic creature with a long neck and
flippers
though some eyewitnesses have said it
resembled a sea serpent or a crocodile
but before we get into the eyewitness
accounts and how many were ultimately
disproved
we need to go back much further in
history to the 6th century ce
and the rumored life of a saint saint
columba was an irish monk who traveled
as a missionary to scotland in 563
almost a century later a biography
written about his work in scotland
includes a story of columba encountering
a water beast at loch ness in 565.
the tale says columba encountered a
group of locals burning the body of a
man they said had been
snatched and mauled by a water beast
while swimming
some people cite this encounter as the
first loch ness monster sighting
which would trace the legend back 1400
years
fast forward to 1817 and newspapers like
the san francisco call and the coventry
evening telegraph
printed stories about sea serpents with
multiple reports continuing
year after year the 19th century also
saw the field of geology emerge
and as fossils resembling these
sightings turned up so did speculation
that
sea serpents were real sparking a debate
that questioned how long
dinosaurs lived and if they might still
linger in the present day
in 1822 loch ness became part of the
caledonian canal
a route that opened coast to coast
travel and shipping the canal expanded
tourism dramatically
and with daily steamship traffic there
was also a rise in reports of sea
serpents and other strange creatures
living in loch ness
solidifying this creature's place in
scottish folklore
these sightings likely informed later
tales of the loch ness creature
even back then one common theory to
explain these sightings
was the survival of a prehistoric marine
creature or its descendant
interestingly mentions of the
plesiosaurus were included in science
fiction of the 19th century as well
in stories like jewels burns journey to
the center of the earth and sir arthur
conan doyle's the lost world
both of these books are about the
discovery of secret worlds on
earth worlds where ancient life has been
preserved
it's the same appeal that makes movies
like jurassic park so popular even today
we want to hold on to the possibility
that we could encounter
living versions of the fossils we
discover it's
not possible nessie didn't really get
global attention until the 1930s
coinciding with the great depression
with morale low
and reality so distressing stories of
the mysterious creature appeal to the
desire for escapism many craved
one particular newspaper report grabbed
the public's attention
three anglers fishing for trout in loch
ness reported to the northern chronicle
in 1930
that they heard terrible noise and saw
the water oddly moving
as something approached them in a
wiggling motion that caused a wave to
rock their boat
as far as witness accounts go not too
significant
but this is the first account that
associated the creature with the word
monster the article read a wave two and
a half feet high caused by some unknown
monster that
presumably inhabits loch ness two other
newspapers would later retell the story
using
monster as well following this reports
of the creature continued to increase
dramatically throughout the 30s in 1933
reporter alex campbell wrote in the
inverness courier
about a creature spotted in loch ness
the story claimed
john and aldi nikai a well-known
businessman and his wife
saw a creature rolling and plunging in
the water
they said it resembled a whale and
disappeared in a boiling
mass of foam aldi macguy described the
creature as having two humps and a total
body length of around
20 feet the article stated loch ness has
for generations been credited with being
the home of a fearsome looking monster
campbell also retold the three angler
story from three years prior
with much more exaggerated and quite
frankly false detail
neither account was taken very seriously
by locals including steamship captain
john mcdonald
with over 50 years traveling in the lock
he said he had never seen anything
strange
adding that what the couple had
described was likely sporting salmon in
a lively mood
leaping out of the water the first
supposed photo of nessie was taken by
hugh gray in november of 1933
in his words the photo showed an object
that rose two or three feet above the
surface of the water
and he considered it a sighting of the
monster
analysis of the photograph led people to
argue that you could possibly see the
rest of the creature underwater
while the photo was believed to be
authentic there was no way to clearly
identify what was actually being
pictured
but the photo added gas to the debate of
whether or not something was lurking
deep in the waters of loch ness
scientific journals began publishing
articles about its rumored existence
the first of these appeared in nature
just a month after grey's photo
which the article cites as recent
evidence also claiming that several
observers have seen
an eel-like monster with humps on its
back a creature with a small head and
long neck
attached to an enormous body and others
something that looked like an upturned
boat
the reporter mentions that he spent half
a day on the lock in july
and saw nothing gotta love 1930s
investigative journalism
nevertheless articles of the time
continue to propose explanations for the
sightings
which have been debated for decades
let's add even more to the list of
possible explanations
large eel grompus porpoise whale shark
seal otter a sunfish crocodile
plesiosaurus
a sea serpent from the middle ages an
unstable mass of drifting pea
or white whale or beluga when the
secretary of state for scotland was
asked
what was being done about the creature
the secretary replied he was in contact
with the chief constable of inverness
shire
who already had five constables
stationed around the lock
none of whom had seen the monster
emphasizing that the creature is
guaranteed protection should it appear
and be threatened
again that longing for wonder takes
precedence
no one wants the mysterious creature to
be killed
they want the possibility to see it
alive for themselves
saving nessie becomes more important
than trying to kill the monster for
proof
which can't be said for other monsters
like the yeti or the chupacabras
yet the loch ness monster might not have
solidified its place in history
without the help of another giant beast
king kong
[Music]
the 1933 movie king kong made the giant
ape
famous and introduced a massive long
neck water monster to the screen
[Music]
the film opened in london on april 17th
just two weeks before
macgy's famous sighting part of the
action on screen depicts a brontosaurus
who attacks humans in the water
before chasing one up a tree and
crushing it in its jaws
effectively the movie reinforced the
thesis that prehistoric animals could be
secretly inhabiting the earth
and nessie was one of them a few months
later on august 4th 1933
another monster report appeared in the
inverness courier
while driving along the shore of loch
ness with his wife a london man named
george spicer
spotted in broad daylight the nearest
approach to a dragon or prehistoric
animal crossing the road
a sketch drawn from spicer's description
produced
this image which looks familiar
because of george spicer's report and
king kong the plesiosaur hypothesis
became the dominant theory of the 20th
century
finally the creature had a recognizable
face to its name
in early 1934 nature published another
article
responding to the supposed evidence up
to that point
claiming with little doubt the creature
was in fact a large gray seal
but every time a loch ness monster
theory is debunked
either another appears or someone makes
an effort to re-establish doubt
making the waters murky again in
november 1933
british naval officer and author rupert
gould who wrote and published his book
the case for the sea serpent in 1930
went to scotland to search for the
creature
he heard of the eyewitness accounts
around loch ness and immediately drew a
connection between
them and the other creatures he had
researched
after months of gathering eyewitness
reports he concluded there was
indeed something in the water although
he was unsure what
exactly he published his findings in the
loch ness monster and others in 1934
which was one of the first books
dedicated to theories of the myth
it is now that we arrive at what you all
probably think of as proof that the loch
ness monster exists the surgeon's
photograph
the photo was given in newspapers by
british surgeon colonel robert wilson
and published april 21
1934 the dark wide body
thin long neck and small head seemed to
come straight from the jurassic era
and the legend was cemented in history
nessie went mainstream and began to pop
up in campaigns for scottish products
and was given both male and female names
like
sandy and archibald between the
newspaper accounts the book the
photographs and the first loch ness
movie
the secret of the lock the myth of the
loch ness monster became so popular
that scotland's official travel
association had to go on
record denying they invented the stories
to encourage
tourism but still the legend grew
the linnaean society of london convened
to discuss the loch ness monster in 1934
aiming to assess if the myth had any
basis in truth
many thought it was a seal or cetacean
mammal of some kind
one scientist remained convinced it was
an otter
they also believed it was hopeless to
compare the creature to any mesozoic
reptile
due to lack of fossil evidence after
this loch ness fervor seemed to die down
until a new photograph appeared in 1951
four silicon stewart captured a
three-humped version of the monster he
said had been bobbing its head and neck
up and down in the water
but it didn't take much time for him to
admit the hoax
he soon admitted the image was really of
three partially covered bales of hay he
placed in the water
in 1957 constance white's more than a
legend
proposed that the loch ness monster
isn't a singular creature
but multiple sightings of descendants of
marine creatures
that entered the lock after the last ice
age trapped in the remains of a glacier
she proposed that the ancestors of
nessie
adapted to the fresh water that over
time turned the saltwater lock into a
freshwater one
for 20 years the legend of nessie
continued undisturbed
fascinating people and building lore
around an unknown creature
then in 1975 the validity of the famous
surgeon's photograph was called into
question a man by the name of ian
wetherill stepped forward and claimed
that his father
faked the famous photograph back in 1933
journalist and big game hunter marmaduke
weatherill
was employed by the daily mail to
investigate the monster
he photographed what he claimed to be
the nessie footprints
zoologists revealed the footprints were
from a leg of a taxidermy hippopotamus
ian claimed his father was so upset that
the nessie footprints weren't well
received
or believed as an act of vengeance he
created the surgeon's photograph
he staged the photo using a toy
submarine with a head made from
wood putty constructed by ian himself
and his stepbrother
he gave it to a fellow prankster who
passed it along to his
friend colonel wilson who gave it to the
press
in 1990 ian's stepbrother christian
sperling confirmed the whole thing
was fake still some people held on to
the hope that something strange was in
loch ness
the debate to formally preserve nessie's
survival began to take shape
with believers arguing that the creature
should be a part of the conservation
of wild creatures and wild plants act of
1975.
the act protected any animal whose
survival is threatened
but only if the animal had a scientific
and a common name
scientists argued that despite no
conclusive proof nessie exists
two photographs taken in 1972 and 1975
left its existence up for debate so they
gave the creature
a formal name part of the name adopts
the name of the lake
and combines it with the greek word
teras which means marvel or wonder and
is often associated with monsters
this part combines the greek words for
diamond and finn
or wing so the name roughly translates
to ness monster with diamond finn
unsurprisingly even with a proper
scientific name
no conclusive evidence of any such
creature emerged
in fact theories disproving the legend
became more advanced as technology
evolved
in 2019 professor neil gemmell a new
zealand geneticist
led a project intended to catalog all
the living species in loch ness
using dna analysis none of the 500
million dna
sequences from 250 samples of loch ness
water
showed any evidence of plesiosaur or
other jurassic reptile dna
and no catfish or sturgeon dna which
also eliminated those theories
but he did find significant amounts of
eel dna
although gemell says that their data
does not give any information about the
size of the eels
he speculates there could be giant eels
in the lock
however locals insist eels are nothing
new in the lake
meaning they can't be the cause of the
sightings over the years
some people also claim the giant eel
theory is unfounded
since no side to side movement from the
creature has ever been reported
more evidence piled up at the jurassic
or pleasey sore theory is untrue
no fossil evidence has been found and
multiple sonar scans of the lake
showed no existence of any large aquatic
creatures
even so on average 10 unexplained
creature sightings on loch
ness are reported every year i think we
want to believe that even in the midst
of so much scientific discovery and
advancement
that there is something unknown
something hidden in the world
still the fact that science hasn't ruled
out the possibility
entirely is what's exciting amateur
researchers monster hunters and
everyday people alike would love to be
the first to prove nessie is real
there's an element of wonder and
excitement that comes from believing in
the impossible
so eyewitness reports continue and
stories of nessie are shared
even as each one before it is debunked
the loch ness monster isn't a monster
that inspires fear
it inspires wonder it's a legend a
series of stories told and retold to
inspire
astonishment and curiosity
okay and we begin oh my god i've been
recording this entire time
okay i'm gonna stop